have you been given notes about
something a story is screenplay and you
are like wait a minute
this is going to kill the aliveness to
it and you had to go back and say well
how do I make these changes that they
want what keep that spark to it that's
tough
that is tough that is to and that that's
that's the writers job is to it is to
take the spirit of the note without
taking the the the mechanics sometimes
because because you know sometimes
you're getting notes from an executive
and they'll say you know I don't like
this scene it's not working or you
should take this out and you've got if
you don't if you're not connected to why
you're telling the story if you're not
connected to the magic then you you can
you can lose that magic bye
and and what here's what will happen is
the executive will read the new draft
and they'll go this isn't working and
you go but I just did what you asked me
to do yeah but a good executive will go
that's not what I asked you to do I told
you this wasn't working and now it's
your job to go fix what I want you to
fix but I'm not a you know they're not a
writer so they're expecting you to do
your job and so you know there are a lot
of really good executives who understand
that when they're giving you a note
they're also expecting you to you know
they're expecting some kind of
alchemical process to happen so that you
can distill the note to its nature and
give them back something that's working
you know it was like Charlie Kaufman he
when he wrote adaptation
he was adapting the orchid thief and
they were expecting an adaptation of
that novel Charlie Kaufman is not in
that novel okay and so he he he
distilled the that he took that novel
and then it went through Charlie Kaufman
and he wrote this really wonderful
brilliant
mad story and when they got it from what
I understand they said what the hell is
this and then a couple of days later
they went oh this is wonderful but it
took them a while I think to get on
board and realized that he that that
that's what they that's why they hired
him because they were they were gonna
get his voice and his thing and so if we
don't trust our voice you know it's a
challenge for the writers you've got to
trust your voice in the midst of all of
the fears if I don't want to lose this
job I don't wanna lose this gig I don't
you know I I don't want to disappoint
you know these people that you know it's
part of it you know you're probably
going to get replaced in Hollywood if
you're a screenwriter doesn't mean that
you did a bad job it just means they're
just they're just covering their asses
you think being a stand-up helped you
come to peace with that or maybe just
because when you're up there I'm sure
it's you're basically naked almost
you're very raw and you've got hecklers
you've got people with all sorts of
agendas throwing stuff at you
metaphorically physically whatever and
you I think at some point you you
probably become more comfortable in that
space maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm just
assuming yes I know I think therapy did
that but I don't think big comedy gave
me a figures you know I didn't know at
all no no it no I I would say yeah
therapy okay yeah yeah and just
realizing that that it's it's the reason
I think that writers or anybody I don't
know where I'm going this it I I think
early on I made I thought as a writer my
identity was tied to my creative work
and that's dangerous
that can that can really mess you up I
can make you a perfectionist that can
make you bitter that can make you a
victim and it's not it's got nothing to
do with my self-worth
and so in fact
I think of if you're a storyteller
that's that's a great luxury and it's a
privilege and so you get to tell stories
and the stories aren't coming from if
they're if you really want to tell great
personal stories you want to be
connected to the universal you want to
be connected to why this is going to be
relatable to other people that's not
gonna make your horse work less personal
it's gonna make it more personal okay
because you're gonna be more willing to
really get into the nitty-gritty of your
struggle because you're going to
understand the transformation I don't
know if that's does that make sense yeah
so when you decided that I'm still gonna
be creative but I'm gonna almost have
like it is it almost like having two
lives one is where you're human and the
other one is where you're a creator
who's having a human experience I know
that sounds so cliche but and then if
someone rejects me for my creator
persona that doesn't mean I'm a bad
human well I yeah I guess so but I mean
yeah yeah like it's it's it always sucks
getting rejected but writers are
constantly being rejected and it's just
part of it like it just the more you do
the more it just rolls off your back
in other words like give me an example
let's say let's say I write a romantic
comedy and it gets into the hands of a
guy who makes horror movies and he goes
we're passing on this they're not
passing on it because it lacks quality
or value they're passing on it because
they make horror movies and that's
Hollywood is that is that it and I'm
just using a broad generalization I'm
talking about genre but but you can
write a script that that may not speak
to the person that doesn't mean that the
script doesn't have value you hear about
these scripts that are in in development
for five ten to fifteen twenty years and
they finally get made and then they win
an Oscar it's because
somebody believed in them and they could
they had a vision and they could see
what that thing wanted to be it's
difficult sometimes to read a screenplay
and be able to see what the movies gonna
be you know so you've got a you've got
to believe in yourself you've gotta
believe in yourself and and I think it
can be easy if something gets rejected
here's the other thing if something's
getting rejected a lot you also need to
have the humility to go well maybe this
isn't doing everything I need it to be
doing okay and so that's where crafts
comes in that's where you really have to
understand what you're trying to do and
and sometimes the you know you can hear
writers there's there's a there's a fine
line between being stubborn and and
having the humility to be teachable you
know because if you don't have the
humility to be teachable and and hear
why something's not working for them you
can kind of get stuck and then going
back to working in the the
maximum-security prison right so the two
times or whatever however many times
sorry you saw that humility in them how
easy was it to have them as sort of a
captive audience sorry that's wrong
scratch that I guess what I'm trying to
say is so many people they go to a great
school and they've kind of been groomed
all their life that they're like this
golden child and they're great and
they're gonna come and and and
everything they do is fantastic and
that's great they have this wonderful
support system right and then I think in
some sense that can hurt them
here in this industry because it's a
rude awakening when someone doesn't
agree with their work doesn't mean they
don't like that person so when you saw
people that maybe had either been born
with more humility or had been forced to
adopt that attitude I think this
business will you will either you know
become humble or bitter so because
you're always going to be getting
rejected
constantly constantly getting rejected
but it's not yeah it's not personal I'm
not sure if I'm answering your question
oh it's great and I love it where it
where does the road diverge for the
humility oh I I agree that totally agree
with you well I think it's just I think
it's just you know I don't know if you
can teach that I don't know if you can
III think it's just humility is gonna
make you a better writer because you're
going to you're going to it's going to
give you humanity you're gonna have
compassion you're going to you know it's
in other words humility is just it's
gonna make your job easier because
you're gonna also have compassion for
yourself you know it's it's going to
it's gonna widen your perspective you're
going to you're gonna see why your
writing isn't doing everything you want
it to do because as writers I think
we've all got blind spots we don't you
know there William Goldman talks about
how you come up with these ideas and you
can see this movie in your head and then
you start to write it and once you start
to write it these ideas become
earthbound you know they're earthbound
they're not there it's it's really hard
work it's really hard work to create a
great story and and I just think
humility is just something that if you
don't have it you might want to find a
way to you know you're gonna become
humble in a Hollywood just by virtue of
the rejection but what you I don't think
there's a way to exercise humility but I
think there there there there is a way
to I think if you have compassion for
yourself and for other people and and
are gentle with yourself and and have
some healthy perception of rejection or
an understanding that I'm not being
rejected it's going it's going to lead
to just a happier life
you